in the next five years the Frontier
Model companies those of us at the very
Cutting Edge who are training the very
largest AI models are going to train
models that are over a thousand times
larger than what you currently see today
in gbt4 instead of just generate new
text in a one shot the model will be
able to generate a sequence of actions
over time AIS that can't just say things
they can also do things it will be able
to make phone calls to other humans to
negotiate it'll be able to call other
AIS in order to establish the right
sequence in a supply chain for example
these capabilities don't just naturally
emerge from the models we attempt to
engineer capabilities and the challenge
for us is to be very deliberate and
precise and careful about those
capabilities that we want to emerge from
the model the governance challenge for
us over the next couple of decades to
ensure that we contain this wave is to
ensure that we always get to impose our
constraints on the trajectory of this
development